l'eau qui baigne les faubourgs de paris
devra bientôt abandonner son lit vieux
de 140 ans le canal saint martin vient
d'être condamné par le pari nouveau
une route express lui succédera allant
du nord au sud
autos et camions remplaceront les
péniches c'était c'est encore le plus
court chemin pour les marchandises
depuis sa création en vertu d'une loi de
floréal en dise
oh
la rivière dourthe qu'il alimente
toujours apporté au quartier un peu de
la campagne aux journées de juillet le
peuple de belleville et de ménilmontant
a retrouvé son courage le long de cette
eau sont en juin 1848 les marronniers
des berges saluèrent les corps tomber
napoléon iii ordonna par décret
d'abaisser et de couvrir la partie du
canal qui jamais en cas d'émeutes les
mouvements de troupes et les
déploiements de cavalerie sur son toit
desjardins apparurent des jets d'eau db
d'aération couronne et d'arbustes
les quais désaffecté de vinca boulevard
enrichi de stature et d'un kiosque à
musique
la moitié du parcours se fait dans un
tunnel
les péniches unes à unes sillonnent
encore plus de 2km réduisent à la
pénombre
l'avis des sous paris c'est encore se
souvenir
place de la bastille un millier de héros
des deux révolutions qui dorment entre
les pierres semble être ensevelis dans
une cathédrale à l'air libre
l'eau c'est à elle prend à sa charge les
bateaux pour les mettre à niveau
le canal en plein air entre couper des
cluses avec ses ponts au ras de l'eau
qui tournent sur eux-mêmes exhale avec
la rumeur vivante des choses le parfum
d'autrefois
riverains et passants s'accordent pas ça
vu quelques instants de rêve adieu
l'hôtel du nord et la chope des singes
adieu la grange aux belles et le
faubourg du temple
et nous nous disons adieu au canal saint
martin
on